But the big three factors
that I think are explaining,
explaining what's happening
on campus are one,
the loss of the unsupervised place
so that the kids have always,
there's always an adult present.
And so they come to college and they
expect there to be an adult or dean,
somebody if there's a conflict.
That's one.
Two is social media which hit just as ign.
So ign,
Internet generation.
This is Jeanne Twinkies work.
You know,
we used to,
we used to think that,
um,
uh,
we used to think that the
millennial generation ends
in 1998 or 2000 let Jean 20
shows looking at for large
datasets that birth year,
1995 kids born in 1995 and
after are really different.
They're values are different.
They have much higher rates
of anxiety and depression,
especially the girls.
Boys have gone up,
grows,
are going way up.
Um,
and the reason it seems to be
that Facebook lowered its age.
Um,
so in 2005,
you had to be a college
student at a certain number
of colleges to get Facebook.
In 2006 you could be any 11 year old who
lies and says that she's 13 and you've
got a Facebook account.
Um,
uh,
but then you're using on your parent's PC,
it's in 2007 the iPhone comes out
and it saturates the market fashion.
Any consumer product ever has.
So by 2010 or 11 a lot of adolescents
have have Facebook and other social
platforms and this is just devastating,
especially to girls
because it's not texting,
texting is just me to you.
You know,
that's back and forth.
That's fine that you know,
we,
when we were kids,
you called your friends on the phone,
that's fine.
The problem seems to be according to 20
it's especially platforms in which he
puts something out and then you wait
and see what everyone says and that
especially as damaging to
girls who already are at
risk of eating disorders and
image disorders.
Okay,
so girls become more susceptible to
negative emotion when they hit puberty?
Well there,
there,
yes.
Yes.
Right.
That's always been the case.
Then there's another issue too
with regards to female aggression.
So,
you know,
it's clearly the case that males are more
likely to be physically damaging slash
aggressive than females are.
But what females use his
reputation savaging that's right.
So that's Nikki cricks work.
Nikki Crick passed away
a couple of years ago,
showed that if you add it all up,
boys and girls equally aggressive,
but the boys aggression is more physical.
The girls,
the more relational.
So if you imagine a bunch of 13,
14 year olds in their middle schools and
then you parachute in a whole bunch of
iPhones,
everybody's got one of their pots,
what are the boys going to do?
They're gonna play video games
and that doesn't hurt anybody,
but the girls are going to use it
to amplify the social interactions.
So this is 20 twenty's explanation.
I think it makes a lot of sense.
So it's a,
it's a catastrophe.
It's a crisis and we're really hurting,
especially the girls.
Um,
so we've got to change
something about that anyway.
But social media is,
is possibly the largest single
reason why things are going haywire.
Campus.
The third big factor,
do you think it's primarily
Facebook or can you tell?
Well,
it's,
it's uh,
uh,
the kids use a lot of different platforms,
but from what I hear,
Instagram,
Facebook,
snapchat,
it again,
the thing is it's one to many.
That's what's bad.
It's anything if it,
if it's,
if it's you put something out there
and you see how many people like it,
that's what's been right.
And there's always the threat that
it'll go viral and the terrible way.
So that's right.
Hammer.
Exactly.
There's this sort of damage
that's limited damage.
Unlimited downside to saying something.
So what do you do?
Careful.
So I don't know if I want to
like that post because you know,
I could get in big trouble for it.
Right.
Well,
the benefit to liking it as minimal
and the potential catastrophe for does
unless you're expected to like it,
in which case you better like
it because if you don't like it,
you'll get in trouble.
So it's a much more of a mob mentality.
Kids are afraid,
you know,
I'm not blaming the kids,
I'm very sympathetic to them.
And these are my kids.
Are My kids are 11 and seven,
they're going to come up into this.
Um,
so the kids have been raised in a,
in a social environment,
it's much more about mob,
mob formation and mob attacks and
Bob defend defenses against mobs.
Um,
and then,
so the third factor then is the political
polarization and that purification or
institutions.
So if you imagine coming up in the 90s
when political polarization is going up,
we're beginning to hate each
other more across party lines,
but it's not that hard.
Not that,
that nasty,
but it's been getting much,
much more hostile.
So that now if someone,
like if someone's is,
if someone goes to a campus,
Republicans meeting,
if it's a Democrat who goes
to a meeting of the campus,
Republicans has happened at UC
Santa Cruz a couple weeks ago,
um,
uh,
and someone finds out,
you know,
so the,
the,
the hatred,
the Cross party hatred
is so much stronger now.
And many of our
institutions are much pure.
So if you went to college in the 90s,
there might've been a few
conservative professors around,
but now there aren't.
So,
as you said before,
it's like exposure therapy.
If you've never encountered
a conservative idea,
and then a conservative like Heather
MacDonald comes to speak on your campus.
Well,
this is like a major
immune response problem.
We've got to get the tribe
together and mob her and you know,
shut her down.
Um,
so those are the,
I mean,
there are many other reasons,
but the loss of unsupervised play,
social media and rice and polarization,
those are the three big ones.